the longest pedestrian suspension bridge
in the world it's open this morning the
Swiss Alps want to go it dangles 28
stories above a rocky ravine and it's
not for the faint of heart I'll say it's
got to put on your big-girl panties for
this that stone takes us across the
engineering spectacle depending on how
you look at it this suspension bridge
either temps or terrifies it was
designed as a white-knuckle shortcut
which shaves a few hours off a hike in
this popular part of the Swiss Alps it
spans the length of about five football
fields and soars over a valley I love it
I love it when someone is walking really
heavy footed then bridge kind of swings
and then whoa where am I nerves dictate
whether it takes 15 minutes or longer to
cross chung bhakti came with a hiking
group from denver only way that you get
that thrill you have to walk it
definitely this will bring more more
tourists Paul summer matter is on the
Town Council of nearby Ronda which
helped raise money to build this only
adding to the suspense is the fact that
the previous bridge had to be closed
after rocks fell on it I'm pretty sure
that'll be okay pretty sure luckily
engineer Theo LIBOR is very sure of his
work and I want to calculate everything
and the one to take care of all so it's
my bridge and I am called mr. bridge
it's his 35th bridge and Lauver says
it's even better than he thought then
that swaying it's by design I want that
people get a bit nervous and a bit upset
why there are lots of other bridges and
this one is a bridge that moves your
heart as you walk out into the middle
here it starts to sway
even more the bridge opened this summer
and draws hundreds of tourists a day
some more willing than others while we
were walking up I was talking about how
this is going to be tough for me because
I have a fear of heights jeff Pavey and
Cindy Conway are from North Carolina why
are you making him do this
they've been married 15 years and like
any successful marriage it's part
compromise and plenty of excitement it
was fine until she started jumping for
CBS this morning Seth Doane high above
Rhonda in Switzerland why do you want to
do something where the guy who built it
says he wants you to be nervous and
upset
oh thank you it moves your heart I and
probably a lot of other things would you
do it sure of course
would you yes uh-uh the only way I'm
going is if you carry me on your back
what'd you say about that
no you won't no instead of that just to
see you react to this possibilities if
this thing's gonna fall down would you
it would be no I understand the need for
big-girl panties talking about ready you
go thank you